our next speaker was born in Paraguay
she is a los angeles-based documentarian
and she's here to talk about some art in
her birth land please welcome out Sharon
Weaver how do you build something to
less than thousand years how do you
foster responsibility and inspire wonder
on future descendants for it to last
that long my name is Sharon Weaver and i
want to show you an example today these
are ancient petroglyphs carved into the
a mumbai hills of paraguay the
petroglyphs have various shapes some
look like stars others look like
counting lines and some look like arrows
point in a specific direction when i was
a child my family and I lived near these
hills my Uncle Joe who's sitting here he
would take us through the thick forest
and to visit the rock art sites and we
all wondered how long have these symbols
been here and what do they mean this is
Galliano and his wife Avelina they are
leaders of a pilot that a tribe in the
area they told us that these hills are
sacred they told us that God created
everything in the universe from this
specific Hill we're going to see just
now so everything originated there and
spread out to the rest of the world this
reminded us of the beautiful star shaped
inscriptions we saw in the rock art and
that's how the solar map project began
we started a crowdfunding campaign and
raise money to make a documentary we
think that if the world can see the
significance of these petroglyphs then
we can all help preserve it we set out
to document the rock art sites and how
they relate to the pilot beta believes
and mythology here is my cousin Frank
the director of the project interviewing
an elder of the tribe her name is near
Sylvia she told us that some of the
world's most renowned archaeologist also
took enormous interest and visited the
sites here on the left is Jose lozada's
who in collaboration with the patella
tendon and the per gram government let
the first archaeological study ever to
be done in the area lettuce and his team
from Spain
help preserve the altimeter cave and
yell tomita cave is considered to be the
Sistine Chapel of the rock art world
when this cave was discovered the
perception that historians had over
earlier ancestors changed they were not
savages but they were driven by
creativity here are some of the popular
motives you can find in Paraguay similar
petroglyphs were found as far as the
north of Brazil and the south of
Argentina but the oldest examples are
found in the a Mumbai hills and they're
dated to be over 5,000 years old years
ago as children we were told by the
indigenous community that everything
originated in the a Mumbai hills and in
2008 archaeologists discovered that this
specific style of South American record
originated in the young Mumbai hills and
spread to the neighboring countries of
Brazil Bolivia and Argentina the
archaeological evidence coincides with
the pilot that I believe that things
started from here despite this the
rocket is still endangered because
Paraguay has one of the highest rates of
the first station in the world due to
slash and burn agriculture it fires like
these reach the walls where the record
is located it would be greatly
deteriorated and these sites have
already suffered lots of deterioration
due to old Paraguay and legends of
buried treasure left behind after the
Triple Alliance war treasure hunters
will follow here sales close and that
led them to the a Mumbai hills where
they came upon this popular motif coming
up right now and when they saw this they
saw arrows clues pointing towards hidden
reaches and they dug at the food of
these walls and in some cases even use
dynamite to clear the rocks but the pie
tauba tera knew there were no treasures
there those symbols don't actually
represent arrows those they were taught
by their ancestors that those symbols
represent the footprint of the nandu the
biggest bird native to South America a
bird related to the ostrich so the
treasure hunters perception was actually
backwards if those symbols were to
indicate direction one would follow it
the wrong way
likewise we hope that the perception
towards these sites will change here is
Nia sylvia sharing stories with the
children unfortunately this effort alone
can no longer protected the Potala Tina
the very guardians of these sites find
not only for the preservation of their
culture but also for their basic human
rights they need a world to see the
relevance of these petroglyphs and help
preserve them for future generations we
believe that these skills should be
declared World Heritage Sites 5,000
years from now we hope that this
physical representation of our ancestors
will persist and now that you know about
the solar map project I hope you can
pass this story along if we can see the
petroglyphs as a manifestation of
culture we can turn the arrows into
footprints then we can help preserve it
to last at least another five thousand
years thank you
you